welcome back to new rock stores the loki
finale brought us all the way back to
the end of time and then broke
our hearts into a thousand multiverse
pieces but at least we know
that our timeline is getting a season
two and hopefully lots more alligator
logo this
is of course rogue theory the show where
we pitched the weirdest theories for of
the nerdy titles that we love my name is
mt and going wrong with me today
we have the host of the philosopher's
podcast eddie
villanueva what's going on eddie what is
up guys mt it is so good seeing you it's
good seeing you angelica and brandon
this is going to be an awesome show i'm
stoked to talk about the season finale
dude right that's the feeling it's kang
it's true
jesus christ and that's actually that's
the more the miss minutes uh reaction
it's
very true i think it's more of like a
good golly like something like that
oh my god
and of course everyone's favorite twitch
streamer and cosplaying a variant
angelica trey what's going on andrea hi
it's good to be back and of course
new rockstars analyst of the month an
off-screen producer
mr brandon what's going on brandon hello
mt hello everybody so great to be back
on rogue theory i stayed up late to
watch the finale and i haven't been able
to sleep because my mind is broken
there you go my heart is broken your
heart is broke my heart is filled
because it's filled
with the love of kang kang is here
entirely
so now getting into our first question
of the day now that kang the conqueror
or to be specific the infinite kang
variants
are the coming threat that sylvie has
now unleashed in the loki finale
could we see another kang appear or get
referenced in an mcu title
before ant-man the wasp quantomania in
february 2023
and loki season 2. and what is king's
end game
is it like an avengers 5 the secret war
is a fantastic four let's hear those
theories guys
yeah i really think we're going to get a
first mention we're not going to get a
first
uh big screen appearance but we'll get a
first mention in the
larger mcu universe in far from home no
doubt
because of the fact that we we're going
to have some sense of multiverse madness
within far from home that is all going
to be
as a result of what we saw in this
season finale the only reason
why and i purposely believe we're now
going to get
harder into that multiverse is because
not only did we establish
nexus events with juan division but now
we're establishing
the creation of multiverses and the
validity
of them being there not the whole like
bait and switch uh with the last
spider-man movie
but i really feel like there's going to
be a strong presence mostly because as
well
uh doctor strange is going to have an
appearance a hand in
far from home and if he's aware i mean
he's the sorcerer supreme i'm pretty
sure he's aware
of the fracture of you know the
multiverse i definitely think kang's
gonna be a big player in multiverse
madness right
but i don't know if he's going to be
prevalent in in spider-man
no way home um i know they're setting up
a lot of multiverse situations but i
think that king's gonna be an
easter egg i think he's going to be
around but he's not going to be a big
player
until multiverse of madness yeah like
maybe in the back maybe there's going to
be like a king poster somewhere
he could be walking through in a
different variation right or just like
how agatha brought up
you know the sorcerer supreme in wanda
vision he we all assumed that dr strange
was going to make an appearance in one
division unfortunately
he didn't yeah but the mention was there
from agatha
and so that kind of brought everything
full circle back to
the mcu proper and made that inclusion
so i
i i agree that's kind of was the premise
of what i was saying is i do believe
he's going to be mentioned
i i honestly don't think i think it
would be too much already on top of
everything that's going on with far
with no way home i got it i think it's
it's going to be more of an effort of
recognizing where the issue is from
and dealing with what's happening there
like i know
you're going to probably get a word drop
from doctor strange or from whoever
who is knowledgeable within the cosmic
universe and the multiverse
structure they're gonna mention him
obviously yeah so he's gonna be the new
easter egg he's the easter king
yeah the easter egg
so eddie says no way home angelica says
um
uh multiverse amanda's what you got
brandon yeah i mean i think those are
both
great assumptions right he's gotta show
up here and there i think what
a fun thing that kang presents that
thanos didn't is
was there was one thanos but now with
kang there's tons of kangs
and i think what might be interesting is
maybe in one of these properties we get
a kang
that is perceived by our heroes to be a
good guy
but we the audience know he's evil like
in theory we saw
the nicest gang in loki right he's the
one
who yes he was pruning off timelines and
stuff but he was letting people live
their lives
now we're gonna get like conquering
kang's fighting each other all the time
but there might be a kang that shows up
in something weird like
like miss marvel or like hawkeye who is
like
ostensibly helping our heroes and they
think like oh this this guy can be
trusted
only to be later revealed that he's the
main bad guy so i think that would be
really fun
is seeing the different versions of kang
that we could see
and yeah i i totally expect to see him
in something like far from home or
multiverse of madness
but i think it'll be really interesting
if he shows up in these properties that
we're
not expecting him to like what if we see
him in venom 2 or like morbius or
something weird like that
where there's like a mention there when
they really start breaking down the
walls of the multiverse
uh i that that would really blow my mind
or even there's going to be another uh
spider-man
into the spider verse the animated it's
gonna be a sequel to that
he could show up in there too like this
could be really fun
and have all these bad kings fighting
each other and
maybe they don't even care about our
heroes maybe they're just like we got to
deal with all the other kings i'm not
worried about the new avengers yeah
like not gonna be a problem like
angelica said make kang the cameo king
the new cameo
let's get it like everywhere kang's from
ever in every universe i like mr king
for that though for that answer i think
i'm going to give you
five thousand five thousand rogue
dollars for that one because i i dig it
i dig it
because like i'd like the idea of kang
showing up as a hero
um and to flip the script because like
you know in young avengers he shows up
as iron lad
and um they seem to be setting up a
young avengers type of situation
um within the the disney plush shows
anyway
so i think we could actually see a a
younger kang hero
and i think that that's um really
plausible
it'd be really interesting to see
because we don't actually see the name
on that structure at the end of uh far
from home
it would be interesting to see if that
structure was
originally already established as like
kang enterprises or something
we just didn't see that side of the
building which if that was the case that
would establish in that particular
timeline
that uh kang was already present as
uh his human counterpart you know the
businessman the industry man
so that would be interesting to see
almost like breadcrumbs that have been
laid throughout
going back through all the films to see
if there were little tidbits here and
there
that actually lent itself to the rival
you know inventor businessman industry
mogul uh
against tony stark um that's that'd be
something to really kind of take some
time to go back through the previous
films
i i no for real i think that's a really
great little thing to do
like i think that they'll i think that
they'll probably will
like maybe even retroactively make
little things like in the background
like oh this was kang or that was king
or like you know
it was like more santa's copters yeah
obviously yes
if if a thanos copter was the thing that
was in the elevator i would have been
equally happy because uh if the battle's
copter was behind all of this it would
make sense
because it's the most powerful uh object
in the marvel universe by the way
can we just say how badass jonathan
majors was
in the first absolutely appearance of
kang
or immortus however whoever he was
personifying there
in that scene jonathan majors is going
to be incredible
in quantum mania and this first
appearance was
so mind-blowing i'm excited to see how
else they're gonna unveil more of the
more
uh angry things so yeah
no i like how you bring that up so like
in terms of this question let's flip it
a little bit
how would you want kang to appear in
your specific pitches
so like eddie so like how like like
exactly how would you
how would you want him to factor into no
way home if like if he was a bigger
presence anyway
every entrance has an apple there you go
all right there you go
apple every time right so
so if you noticed in in low-key right he
had a green apple
the conqueror version is going to have a
red apple so that's how you can tell
the valence of the king
and then everyone's going to get
confused because there's going to be
like the the yellow apple at one point
it's going to be like a warning sign
they're going to run out of apple
is going to have a pink lady apple you
know things like that
who's got a honey crisp i trust i'll
tell you what
oh no if i if i were to pitch it to
to marvel i would say that the best way
to go about
retconning uh kang back into the mcu
is to uh ultimately be the man
who has a hand behind what happened to
peter parker's parents uh because we
have yet to see
that information come to light all we
know is of aunt may
um if there was some part like maybe
part of the industry that his parents
worked for or his dad worked for
kind of like how they were doing with
andrew garfield in the sony spider-man
universe something along those lines
where that was something he was a part
of and maybe
peter parker's dad got too close to what
the bigger picture was
and but i i feel like that probably be
the best place to shoehorn
shoehorn him in to the overall mcu
because like i said that's a backstory
we haven't
unveiled yet and it would be a good way
to kind of begin moving it towards that
uh
spider-verse kind of the no way home
film that is a super creative idea
i love i dig it so much how how would
you implement kang
in um multiverse of madness angelica the
fun thing with kang or at least
you know we're only going off of one
precedent here from loki as like he
pops in towards the end like hang is
end game so i feel like with multiverse
of madness
maybe king will pop in not like
be established as a character or as
villain right at the start
you know i think we're gonna get some
wanda involvement in there
um after one division you know she's set
up as a little bit of like this
wild card coming into her powers here um
and then we're going to
have kang pop in and then everyone's
gonna essentially be like oh crap we
need to
we need to fight this guy um and it's
gonna be epic and he's gonna have that
apple and it's gonna be such a
villainous
entrance it's gonna be so good i'm so
excited to see
his like final form his final outfit i
i just know jonathan majors is going to
do such a good job
i hope multiverse of madness starts with
like doctor strange in the kitchen
like making making a sandwich or
something at the moment uh
you know uh good kang dies and
everything starts splitting and he's
just like
one of those like he is one of those
obi-wan moments when alderaan got blown
up or he's like oh
oh boy things are bad i gotta go i
should have showed up in new jersey
what am i doing yeah i gotta get my [ __ ]
together yeah i think that's gonna be a
big
thing too because you know with loki
we don't know where a lot of these um
the timing of them so yeah we could be
there right at that
that point where sylvie does the deed
and now you know the timeline's been
changed and altered
irreparably so yeah that could be cool
yeah i do what you were saying about
you know spider-man far from home and
the ending of that and we don't see the
tower i didn't even think about the idea
because that
takes place so far after in game and
ostensibly these events of loki
happened before that or as that was
going on
that it could have happened during that
movie and no one's aware right
maybe the only characters in the
multiverses that know of these changes
are obviously the loki we know from the
show because he shows up and he's
surprised by the statue
ravona rinslayer who went off in her
little time door and who knows where she
is or what she downloaded
uh and then obviously the kang's know
what are going on
the living kings uh so yeah it's crazy
to think that like these things could
have changed
and i love the idea that they you know
marvel's been ahead of it and has been
planting things
you know when they did the secret
invasion storyline they set up stuff
years in advance in the comic books and
it really paid off well so i'm excited
i think marvel's feeling that power they
could do no wrong the mcu they're
and i really hope they start like
subverting our expectations
you know with these stories we kind of
know like i would be interested to see
if
kang is a richard's or not yeah you know
maybe they won't go down that
that line i'm actually hoping they do
like a hundred percent can you imagine
if if they establish this king as
nathaniel richards
what the implications are with the first
family marvel may actually take marvel
and disney might actually take that big
step
in when they form the first family it
may be a mixed race family
and that's something that we haven't
seen yes that would be great
that would be a huge implication in the
overall arc of what mcu what the mcu
what marvel what disney's trying to do
and i'm all for it like if he is the son
of reed richards
i want to see how i mean it's laying the
groundwork for things that we have yet
to see
within the mcu that previous iterations
have pretty much all but fail like just
all failed uh completely
um so this this implication could really
have
huge ramifications in the overall marvel
cinematic universe
and he said that with his chest like
failed completely
2015 we don't speak of that no um but no
yes no these are all
amazing answers honestly i'm gonna give
everybody five thousand points everyone
gets
five thousand baby
i've inflated the system the rogue
dollars market is out of control
yeah it must be stopped we've got some
more theories about a character that
wasn't in this episode of loki but was
in the news anyway but first
a few words from the folks that help us
make rogue theory possible
big news we've just released a loki
gator sticker
and a mobius on a jet ski t-shirt that
lets us all about the dream
that poor mobius wasn't able to in the
season of loki i mean what the what the
hell and this is the last week to grab
yourself some of the loki inspired merch
over at newrockstarsmerch.com including
our limited edition latest obsession
series low key out of time which i'm
wearing
right now it's the coolest shirt i've
ever worn um
it makes me feel like a badass even
though i'm not i'm the biggest nerd of
all time but some sizes and styles have
already sold out and most of the rest of
them will be getting pruned from our
timeline
this week so hurry up and show your
support for new rockstars and get
yourself some cool
limited edition gear at
newrocksourcemerch.com when it comes to
saving time and working more efficiently
it's the little things that start adding
up and hogging time in your day
i send a lot of emails and messages and
the grammar in those can be a mess so
it's super nice to have grammarly there
to point out my mistakes instantly
saving me the time and embarrassment
from looking like i type with my feet
i would never do that that's disgusting
well it's that's gross
grammarly premium helps you get your
message across quickly without repeated
or unnecessary words adding clarity to
your written communications and with a
free version of grammarly you're safe
from embarrassing basic spelling
grammar and punctuation mistakes
grammarly premium's advanced time-saving
features help you write more clearly and
efficiently and it has seamless
integration
with microsoft office your internet
browser your phone and more so close all
those thesaurus tabs and save the
research time with vocabulary
suggestions
for more compelling word choices and get
straight to the point with clarity
suggestions that eliminate unnecessary
or redundant words and phrases
so hit send with confidence and get your
point across more effectively with
grammarly premium and get 20
off grammarly premium by signing up at
grammarly.com
rogue that is twenty percent off at
g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y
dot com slash rogue it's summer and you
might actually be leaving the house
whether or not you're heading out to
hang out with friends or venturing to a
movie theater for the first time in a
year
you want to look good and that's where
faraday comes in they make the perfect
clothes for summer ferrity is a
family-run brand making
high-quality timeless clothing with
modern design and functionality you know
when you're searching for that ideal
summer outfit that fits so perfectly
that it feels almost too good to be
vintage but it still looks like it might
be
well that's verity that's what they do i
saw eric in a great t-shirt the other
day and it turns out it was a ferrari
t-shirt i was like bro
why are you looking so damn good he was
like bro this is verdy baby i was like
oh [ __ ] he looked so cool and it made me
shirt jealous like
i have this shirt on and it made me
shirt jealous still and they're so
confident in the quality of their stuff
they have a lifetime
guarantee of quality which means that
they will place or fix your clothes
forever no matter what like if it gets
shot up with bullet holes if you're luke
cage they will fix your shirts forever
no matter what they're just that
confident and to top it all off faraday
is giving the rogue theory audience
20 off that is 20 off so
stock up on all your clothes for summer
now head to faradybrand.com and use code
rogue at checkout to snag
20 off all of your summer gear that is
rogue at faraday f-a-h-e-r-t-y brand.com
for 20
off mail and ship anytime anywhere right
from your computer with stamps.com send
letters ship packages and pay less
a lot less with discounted rates from
usps and ups
when we ship things here at new
rockstars we use stamps.com the
convenience is the biggest factor for us
they make it easy for small businesses
to mail and ship without needing to take
a trip to the post office
you can print official us postage and
shipping labels 24
7 without having to leave your desk or
buy fancy equipment and all you need is
your computer
and a standard printer and once your
mail is ready just schedule a pick up
and drop it off it's that simple
stamps.com is a no-brainer saving nearly
1 million small business owners time and
money so stop wasting time going to the
post office and go to stamps.com instead
and there's no risk and with our promo
code rogue you get a special offer
that includes a four-week trial and plus
free postage and a digital scale and no
long-term commitments or contracts so
just go to stance.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in rogue that is stamps.com
microphone
promo code roguestamps.com never go to
the post office again
all right homies let's dive into you
think uh dracop
used stamps.com to send women around the
world
um i i think so i think that they have
that on the i don't know their table not
a good ad for them
they don't like to talk about it they
don't like to talk about it but he's a
big business for them
anyway topic two now that loki knows
kang is behind the tva and that an even
more evil king has overtaken the tva
he now finds himself stuck in where does
loki go from here i mean can the tv even
be destroyed
can it be retaken control over are loki
and still be doomed
to ever love each other will mobius ever
get his jet ski what's going to happen
in season two guys
okay run run slayer gets anywhere
gets a sword well here's the thing the
whole plot of season two
it's just her shopping first my hope is
that we we get a chance
to delve more into who uh ravana rents
lair is
overall in the comics i mean if we get
an opportunity to see her
kind of follow in those footsteps to
becoming terminix uh terminatrix sorry
uh
we'll get a chance to see a whole
another side of uh gugum bathra
as a performer uh kind of embody that
you know assassin warrior
that uh would really be great to see
coming back to take revenge on
uh kang um in in the comics obviously
there's like a love-hate relationship
that goes on between the two of them
um but right at some point in time
ravona
ends up becoming terminatrix and even at
one point embodies nebula as a as a
persona
um but it'd be great to see her kind of
step out in season two
and be almost like this xena warrior
type esque
uh badass assassin who travels with
space pirates kind of thing
that'd be really cool to see and
explored as we move forward
on the the tv show level on the loki tv
show level
obviously kang is still going to be a
very big part of the mcu and i don't
really think
when you have somebody who embodies the
beginning and end of time and it
essentially
reincarnates you don't really get rid of
people like that so
yes i'm hoping that's where they kind of
traverse into for the next season
yeah it would be interesting to see
ravona you know
get to kang eventually and then decide
like i'm going to team up with this guy
i like what he's saying it's always fun
when the character makes the conscious
choice
to be evil when you're like no you
should be good and they're like master
that yeah
and it will be fun it reminds me of uh
the
the daredevil series on netflix when the
king
pins lady i forget her name how rude of
me terrible i fail the bechtel test uh
uh when she decides like i'm going with
kingpin let's be bad
let's run this town you know that's a
lot of fun
vanessa yeah i think it's vanessa editor
making me look like a decent human being
please i just imagined him saying it in
his voice i'm like what is his name and
just i just imagined
vanessa he says it's so weird it's like
so creepy it's like
vanessa i know you know i
so when i have a question and maybe i'm
just crazy but like when
when hunter b-15 took them to go see
ravonna uh
the ver a variant of ravona is this the
road is this do we think this ravona is
still
a normal person on earth on our prime
earth in the mcu like because the
variant is from some other
timeline so the prime one still is at
fdr school ostensibly
i think that it yeah i think it's that's
just the mcu or like the the indian
universe variant of
rents layer that's what i assumed yeah
um and then that the rents layer that we
know is just from either another
universe completely or just
uh yeah just like a completely different
native universe what do you what do you
guys think i mean i think for like
season two
uh it's interesting that so loki goes
back and he finds that like the tva is
still there
and all that's really changed is like
who's the boss now so it's
i i guess that establishes that the
kang's they like the tva
it's not like the other kang's not that
the the king we saw that he who remains
was using the tva
to keep the other kangs out but it's
also i think all the other kings see the
value of the tva like they don't want it
to go away
whoever is going to get to the top spot
needs to have the tva at his disposal
yeah so maybe yeah
you know loki might take the opportunity
in season two to destroy the tva
because maybe that's the only way to get
rid of kang is to get rid of the tva
it's too much power
okay so but how is he going to do that
easier
right they got to use the power of love
they gotta kiss that's why they
they're separated now they just gotta
meet up and kiss and destroy the tv
dude yeah maybe what if he kisses
moebius on the mouth
and that wakes him up a mobius kid
together would do it because he inspired
he inspired mobius before to burn it to
the ground
you know he gave him the spark he can do
it again yeah exactly
burning with the flames of their love
you know and
um you brought up an interesting point
with ravona
and talking about her different variants
because what if
what if the current ravona i don't think
this is gonna be it because her
trajectory just seems
too strong but what if she does go
into a villainous direction and then the
ravono we saw
at the school um i don't know the other
ravona like
they hook up you know they talk to each
other and
maybe one of them dies and that's part
of
you know like maybe the school ravona
becomes yeah
like a good version or something like
that there's a lot
of gamora they switch them out yeah
there's
a lot there that they can work with um
i definitely think ren slayer is going
to be or avona is going to be a big
deal in season two i think that
um one of my big questions is what's
gonna happen with sylvie
we're gonna probably get that answered
hopefully within like the first few
episodes just assuming that they
continue with the the six
episode streak here in season two yeah
um is still the okay because we saw how
quickly that turnaround was with the tva
and with kang a bad maybe evil king
conqueror kane
taking over and does that mean that
you know he popped up where sylvie
currently is like how quick was that
turnaround is sylvia all right
um i think that season two is going to
be
loki our main loki here from season one
trying to convince mobius again
we're gonna have this like twisted
groundhog day effect from season
one into season two and they're gonna be
hunting down sylvie
they're going to be um probably
trying to defeat this way worse version
of king the conqueror version and it's
hopefully going to have a water temple
episode where mobius is on his jet ski
and there's alligator loki and um they
have to fight
i don't know like a water version of
king that's what i'm hoping for
i need a i need a whole swamp first
asgard that's all
coming together for me oh my god i need
water kang
just like different like pokemon
versions of keg like there's a fire keg
a rock cake
yeah psychic oh yeah it's a whole swamp
asgard
loki gator donkey kang yes donkey king
number one
that's the first priority give us donkey
kang and then we'll get
water kang and the rest here here's a
question i have for you guys seeing as
like
understanding the different variants of
uh rents layer
is there a possibility that the current
nebula is actually a variant of red
slayer
that is really interesting because there
is there's a there's a part of the
uh avengers storyline where she is
actually
she is nebula throughout some of those
stories
now that'd be interesting if at some
point in time rensselaer gets to this
point where she has to
get rid of her other variants and maybe
she has to go after nebula for some
reason to go
and destroy her because of some
information or because of some
reason why her existence cannot kill you
know continue
that'd be wild if they made the network
that would be
super nuts if like she ends up being
like a nebula variant
yeah honestly at this point that's
definitely within the realm of
possibilities
it just i guess depends on you know how
well that fits into
the the mcu you know next phase
storyline here
but that's a really interesting point
you bring up i found it
most most interesting that when loki
comes back to the tva
and they're like oh you're an analyst
right they don't even recognize him as a
loki
yeah so is this a tva now that doesn't
know any loki's
has this kang somehow wiped out all the
loki's and this is the only loki that
remains and silvi
ostensibly in the citadel like they're
the only loki's left now
are all the loki's gone where's
alligator loki that's all i want to make
sure he's safe
he doesn't look like loki so that's fine
maybe he doesn't recognize him but
the fact that he didn't even recognize
him as a loki so many loki variants look
like loki
is very strange yes i think that was
very
interesting i'm just like what's going
on here like why don't you know
loki was a very big deal to the tv like
two seconds ago you only know you worked
for the tpa because they have that
awesome
shirt yeah weird shirt where the collar
goes down and there's no
it goes all the way down i'm fascinated
by the shirt that tva wears
that ending so how do they get the tie
in there i don't understand right
that ending was so reminiscent of tim
burton's planet of the apes
uh in just the way the the the like oh
the confusion and the recognition of
there's a new history that's been formed
that he's not aware of
uh i i really like that kind of call to
you know what tim burton did there
but the the ultimate kind of question
now is
are variants still being pruned
because now that there's a different you
know morbius or now that there's a
different uh
immortus slash kang who's running things
there's there was no like for the first
thing you would have been considering
if you were more mobius is is he a
variant who got loose or something like
that seems to be
that was the priority mindset for a lot
of them
um and now it was more of a mindset of
oh he's just another person here um
which means maybe they did away with
pruning maybe there's a whole another
punishment
that's even worse than pruning that
they're doing or maybe
there's just there's a lot of questions
that that final scene really does drudge
up
for marvel fans because now we're
looking at a whole new structure
of an organization that we spent six
episodes trying to recognize and
understand
and even see who was the man behind the
curtain well yeah wouldn't that defeat
the purpose of the tva or at least the
purpose that we
know for the tva in season one because
it exists outside of time
and it was to protect the sacred
timeline so this
primary timeline keeping the current
kang
in power and in control and from
having it branch off and loki was a huge
threat to that
in so many of them so yeah that's uh
that's a good point but at the same time
then that would have to restructure the
entire tva into a whole new purpose
and what would that be which he's had a
lifetime to do now
yeah policing in some different sense
maybe even the focus of the tva now
is not to maintain a sacred timeline but
it's to
allow and to continue the branching
timeline to continue to create
as much chaos to so where everything
else continues out there
and immortus can continue his war on
the vast multiverse galaxy well then
that would be just letting the loki's
run free then because they they
branch things off so much causing so
many nexus events
that's why he wiped out all the loki's i
mean this t this ken could be using the
tva
maybe he's gonna set up the void now as
like his chronopolis or whatever he's
gonna go start collecting what he wants
and instead of it being like you know uh
the jail for all the variants it's gonna
become
like his kingdom now this is where he's
gonna he's gonna get out of the citadel
and rule from the void
uh and use the tva to go pick up
whatever he wants go conquer whatever he
wants to conquer
all i'm saying is all i want to see at
the end are the in the next season
is the return of richard egaran that's
what i want to see i want to see him
come back i want to see him
you know continue his role as old loki
it was just he was wonderful and
although it was only for a short time
his impact in the series was just so
vast so
oh yeah for sure i think he definitely
deserved that uh guest emmy as well
but then that's taking away his glorious
purpose or i guess
giving him a new a new chance to find
more glorious purpose but it's kind of
simple you could come back in the new
season as king
king loki yeah i definitely don't think
that he died in that episode
like i'm i'm very much on the train of
like yeah loki's
this is what he does the loki's just
fake their own deaths
and survive and so like you know this
happened with uh you know thor the dark
world
oh no it's so sad loki died oh no he's
okay
he didn't actually make a sacrifice for
thor and all that stuff
this is what they do like we're always
on this like
constant like i don't know cycle of like
believing loki's dead
and they're not really dead so i would
suspect a a a return of richard e grant
in season two but that's just me
okay that's fair i'm not gonna lie so i
had i had
the realm of possibilities all open i
actually thought
loki might have died in this finale
episode he didn't
but i i was like what if he dies again
like so help me god this man had his
back turned to kang
so long i mean i know you about you
didn't learn the first time
you about to get stabbed in the back
for real that's how you know kang was
done
he was too busy re-enacting when harry
met sally and trying to get things going
with sylvia and he forgot all about the
bad guy behind him
there was uh there's been many a fight
scenes where i yell make out but last
night's or this finale episode
was a prime example of that i was like
like the whole time by myself
that's how i stop all the fights i'm in
i'm like you want to make out and they
stop fighting so i'm good
exactly they threw me out of creed 2
because i kept yelling make out
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and that was to sylvester stallone and
off london that wasn't even too much
20 30 years in the making just do it
already come on jeez let's just get
creed to kiss all of his appointments
there you go
okay so to recap eddie wants uh to see a
terminatrix
in season two which is great um and
brandon said he wanted loki to just
try to burn the tv to the ground if i'm
not mistaken and angelico
baby once uh or suspects a groundhog day
type scenario where like you know
basically doing
sort of the same things again but like
in a new different way which is
really interesting sort of like how like
the good place sort of like
switched up their formula with season
two it's like sort of the same thing but
different
but yeah i do like the terminatrix
a thing a lot though because i really
want to see a terra matrix
show up in the mcu i wonder how they
would do that so for that
i'm going to give eddie 6 000 rogue
bucks with um i'mma give 5000
to the other two making eddie with a 1
000 point lead
so far but the show the game show is not
over
is this a game show i don't know i think
we're just pretty serious
you just spoke true do the points
according to kang everything is a game
it's a question
exactly all money is imaginary it's just
ones and zeroes that exist
in cyberspace it's true ones and zeros
from one place to another
nothing's real nothing's real society is
fake we could revolt at any time anyway
moving out to the real question
um so today's real question is so
i know if you guys saw but deadpool and
korg teamed up this week in the most
amazing
piece of marketing i've ever seen in my
days to do a trailer reaction
for the upcoming film free guide so
which comic book character or characters
would you like to see doing reaction
videos
and just general streaming content
online i really
think for me the most entertaining
because i'm thinking entertaining
the most entertaining duo that i would
want to see
do promos and stuff like that would be
uh the grand master
and phil coulson just two of the most
opposite folks
the grand master being the jeff gold
bloomiest gloomiest person he could be
and phil coulson doing his best to try
to stay as the straight man but just
breaking every time because it's jeff
goldblum i mean let's be honest with
people
the man is an international treasure you
cannot
not smile when you look at it everyone
loves the bloom bro
everyone loves the bloom i think the
the ideal choice uh has got to be you at
least gotta have
mojo from the mojo verse okay
he can't find any good television he's
got opinions on everything
he's got no spine he just wants to sit
there and like react to things
but he's not going to be fun for him
because he's just going to be he's going
to hate everything he's gonna think it's
all terrible
so he needs like a partner and i think
you gotta bring in you gotta bring in
like professor x right as his partner
on the show because then you don't need
a comment section because professor x
can just hear all the comments
like live as they're coming in he knows
exactly who's saying them and he can
call him out
and if he wants to as we know from logan
he can you know give him a stroke or
something if
their comment is inappropriate no more
shadow banning
you just give them a stroke wherever
they are boom damn
wow that's the show that's the show with
risk that i would watch
okay okay so mojo and professor max i
would have never dreamed of that combo
but okay it's a great combo angelica
what do you got
um so i would like to see the ladies
take over i want to see like a weird
dynamic again
so maybe like hella and
i don't know mantis or hmm oh my god i
love that combo yeah like she-hulk um we
could throw in
boner in there somewhere that's not lady
but it would be
fun but i would like to see you soon
silver i'm not gonna catch it during the
reaction be hilarious
don't do the show she-hulk and boner
would be good because like she hulk
would be super smart and like on task
and like boner would find all the dumb
videos they could watch because he's on
the internet all day exactly
just like watching he's just a normal
guy
yeah and then she could just pick him up
and throw him across the room
very true and she hopes great because
she hulk is also really meta just like
deadpool
so so like which which uh which combo
are you going for angelica you're gonna
go for the hello or
well i'll settle in on the ladies taking
over
so maybe she hulk is the primary host
and then we've got
boner in there okay hanging out yeah i
think it's a fun dynamic
i think that's a really fun dynamic and
for that dynamic i'm gonna give you
7 000 because i dig it it's like it's
it's pretty it's pretty crazy
so i'm gonna give seven thousand to miss
angelica trey
and they're reviewing the guy again for
some reason
and for mojo and professor rex i'm gonna
give three six thousand and also for
grand master and coast another six
thousand
which i think makes angelica the winner
from the sticker makes this a tie
this is your game show is it a tie it's
a tie it's a tie
oh my god so i guess what should we do
to be a tiebreaker oh my god
celebrate our best [ __ ] our best owen
wilson wow
yes okay we're gonna do a wow wow
angelica must have read the comic book
comments from the last video
okay what you got angelica what you got
for a while wow
oh okay a nice slow that's like a subtle
wow that's like you're at the grocery
store and you see like a great deal on
mistakes i know right it's like where am
i
i do okay okay pretty good what you got
eddie
wow [ __ ] oh my god that's
pretty good okay that's pretty that's uh
they're both really good
[ __ ] um you know what
i'ma give i'm gonna give it to angelica
because it was a different kind of wow
it was a nice
soft wow it was a nice win
he's he's a little soft-spoken sometimes
owen and moebius so
so makes angelica are winner
she earned it um but all these theories
were amazing as always and
that is it for our episode of rogue
theory thank you so much to our guests
angelica trey
eddie villanueva an ice cream producer
brandon for joining us you guys are
seriously the best it's super smart and
i love just keeping up with you
so please support all of their content
and what they do
please um go listen to the film film
philosopher's podcast i don't know why i
struggled to say that please listen to
the film the officers first podcast
follow um yeah please follow angelica on
twitch as well
and just follow off screen producer
brandon on twitter at grimm and barrack
because he's just
right here find me follow me good luck
yes they're all great people doing great
things so please support what they do
and of course support our channel by
checking out our new loki theme merch at
newrockstarsmerch.com you can follow me
at mastertainment
follow angelica
thanks so much for watching everybody we
will see you guys later
goodbye goodbye
[Music]
you